hey guys I am live right now on my
youtube channel hello I am here at Apple
Park well this is actually the Steve
Jobs theater and the event is about to
start and I just wanted to do a little
livestream because I love you guys are
super hyped up and needless to say I'm
extremely hyped up as well so I brought
a little friend here this is the
original iPhone so back in 2007 I was in
San Francisco when they launched this
first phone and I wasn't at the event
but I was nearby and then I got to
actually kind of go in and see it up
close there's a video somewhere if you
want to check that out but I'm Nev you
guys a quick little tour I've been
shooting some videos so they'll be a
vlog probably losing my voice because
I've already been so excited but I'll be
posting a vlog later of everything but
here it is this is the Steve Jobs
theater it is behind me so I'll take you
guys for a quick little cruise around it
is extremely hot so I'm kind of sweating
let me put my phone away I've got two
cameras in this backpack
I've got hard drive I've got snacks
I've got water and this is it this is
what we're doing so let's take you on a
quick tour I hope you guys are doing
well I'm doing exceptionally well I'm so
excited
I've already probably said that 40 times
let's go on a quick little trip around
see jobs theater okay let me put you
guys around ready here it is this is the
theater the actual theater is downstairs
which is kind of interesting so I
haven't been downstairs yet I've only
been up here kind of walking around
doing loops
it's just I'm speechless to be
completely honest with you
I'm just saying filler words now until I
can get over here to show you guys the
actual Apple Park I don't even think
Apple employees have even started
checking in to work still having things
under construction if you look on like
Google Maps or Apple Maps like all
around surrounding this entire area
there's still construction going on
which I'm assuming they're still
construction going on but they need it
quite nicely so look look look down
there in the theater
[Music]
what do I say what do I say I don't know
I have nothing as an I'm freaking out
also
as soon as I walked up to the entrance I
saw Steve Wozniak hi hello
what everybody's doing there's please
thanks
here it is
what do I say I don't know what to say
look at this fresh growth that we've got
here with only people here
what do you think I don't know what to
say
the hype has never been a lot of people
I need to find some friends because I'm
all alone are in a time of need the
entrance here
I guess I'll take you guys inside let's
go ahead
this is my first time inside the theater
I'm gonna have to reenact this for my
vlog but this sit we're inside
[Music]
hello welcome to the live stream I
haven't done in years but this is pretty
good times
are you excited like look at this yeah
this is my first time inside yep okay
well guys I'm gonna let you go and stay
tuned